c'est vrai qu'on entende le maire
adjoint de villeneuve la garenne yeux se
sont passées les faits abdellahi tomar
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
maire adjoint de la commune de
villeneuve la garenne et vous allez nous
donner les éléments dont vous disposez
puisque de par fonction qu'est ce qu'on
vous a réellement rapporté de la soirée
de samedi soir est cet accident et je
sais que vous voulez pousser un coup de
gueule qu'est ce qui se passe à beit
omar alors dites-nous juste quelques
éléments avant de répondre à vos
questions cyril mercialys mais par
rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit par
rapport à noir il faut quand même
reconnaître de manière salutaire cheikh
anwar que ce jeune homme a reconnu un
certain nombre de thors au travers de
son avocat sur son lit d'hôpital où il
reconnaît qu'effectivement 1
il roulait sans casque 2 qui roulait à
vive allure quand même quelque chose
qu'il faut quand même lui reconnaître
aujourd'hui ce soir et c'est plutôt ça
tu cette salutaire de sa part puisqu'on
a dépeint quand même je dirais un
portrait clair c'est négatif notamment
par mois sont passés et ça c'est vrai
qu'il faut l'avouer il a acquis la il
avoué sur son lit d'hôpital aujourd'hui
la véritable question parce que je tiens
à préciser série de moi je n'étais pas
sûr sur les sur les volets d'une mesure
au moment des faits c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé à ce que guy que
vous voyez d'ailleurs dans l'un d'eux
des reportages que vous avez passé tout
à l'heure on le voyait la caméra soit
présent ce soir la question aujourd'hui
c'est la mise en danger
disproportionné par rapport je dirais
l'infraction commise quand on parle du
port de casque effectivement le fait de
rouler autres sur une moto non
homologuée
mais aussi le moyen qui a été utilisée
pour stopper le jeune en question
moi ce qui m'a frappé cyril quand je me
suis rendu sur place et quand j'ai eu
les premiers témoignages c'est que vous
savez ça s'est passé en pied d'immeuble
il ya comme vous l'avez préciser tout à
l'heure beaucoup d'habitants qui sont
continuellement donc les mois les
témoins ne manquent pas si je puis dire
et moi j'ai été frappé par une dame qui
est descendu pour venir me rencontrer en
me disant monsieur je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce que le jeune a fait
mais en tout cas ce que la police a fait
je ne peux pas l'accepter
beaucoup ont cru au départ qu'il
s'agissait d'un accident entre le motard
et un véhicule hummer j'imaginais une
mac os x c'est est une passat un break
noir donc si vos policiers
extérieur du véhicule on aura identifié
effectivement des policiers ça c'est le
premier régiment deuxième élément ce qui
est intriguant c'est effectivement quand
je me suis rendu sur place c'est la
trace de freinage
on voit très bien qu'il a essayé
d'éviter quelque chose d'accord c'est
assez c'est assez c'est assez flagrant
j'ai pu prendre j'ai pu prendre en photo
donc aujourd'hui clairement
effectivement villeneuve la garenne qui
est une ville connue pour être une ville
calme et paisible connaît quelques
quelques tensions par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé et c'est regrettable je
pense que du côté des fonctionnaires de
police
comme du côté des de la famille assure
ou des habitants personne ne peut se
réjouir de la situer ce qui se passe à
john oui c'est j'aurais pu perdre
l'usagé de sa jambe
si ce n'est plus au vu de la violence de
l'impact et du choc
moi j'avais gagné la chaussée laissant
l'essentiel rybinski me laver grail a et
b aujourd'hui ça ça va bien c'est que
c'est les jeunes comptent appeler les
sapeurs pompiers mais deuxième élément
qu'il faut préciser série les dans aucun
média ça n'a été dit ni dans la presse
écrite
c'est la question qu'il faut se poser je
la poserai aussi tout à l'heure à noir
ccc forces de police parce que encore
une fois ce n'était pas des policiers de
villeneuve la garenne
c'est une patrouille départementale qui
circulait à ce moment là qu'ils ne
connaissent pas ces territoires qui ne
connaissaient pas ces jeunes dont qui
n'ont pas ce lien
je dirais fort avec avec cette jeunesse
parce que la question elle est très
claire
est-ce que ça se serait passé si c'est
des effectifs de police de villeneuve la
garenne
je ne pense pas vu qu'il n'avait pas de
case qu'il était identifié il aurait pu
à un moment donné l'interpellé pour lui
faire le reproche qui était qui était
qui était celui de ne pas effectivement
vous voulez avec ce type de moto et
encore une fois je ne veux prendre ici
la défense de deux personnes mais ce que
l'on souhaite aujourd'hui et c'est
d'ailleurs le courrier que je vais
envoyer avec un certain nombre de
collègues élus demain au maire c'est que
toute la vérité et toute la transparence
soit faite sur ces sur cette affaire car
elle interroge de manière générale un
élément très important il ya quelques
mois on a déjà connu un incident à peu
près du même type avec encore une fois
les interventions de fonctionnaire de
police extérieur à la ville
je me suis rendu sur place et des
collègues à moi des agents de
territoriaux et essayer d'apporter un
soutien à un jeune qui venait de
connaître un accident ils ont été
placardées contre le mur je suis arrivé
en disant vous êtes dans un
établissement
je dirais un bâtiment public de la ville
j'ai été repoussés violemment par le
fonctionnaire de police qui m'a dit
dégage ici c'est la police donc je peux
comprendre comme l'a dit yanuar tout à
l'heure effectivement on en période de
noël pardon on est en période de
confinement les esprits sont bien sûr
c'est tendu il s'agit du côté de la
preuve